[MUSIC INTRO]
OMAR RUTLEDGE: My
name is Omar Rutledge.
When I was 19, I was
an infantry soldier
during the US invasion of Iraq.
I found that returning
home was just
the beginning of my challenges.
Everything seemed
totally different,
even though it
all look the same.
Somehow, the war changed me.
But how?
And why?
When I got out of
the Army, I wanted
to understand how experiencing
trauma changes the brain
and, more importantly, to try
to develop better treatments
to help people get
back to normal.
This inspired me to
become a neuroscientist.
As a graduate
student at MIT, I'm
learning how to
investigate the brain
through magnetic
resonance imaging or MRI.
I am designing a clinical
trial to investigate
if the alternative medicine CBD
has an effect on social anxiety
disorder, the most common
anxiety disorder in the US.
My hope is this research will
allow us to better understand
the effects of this
drug and how it
may be useful for the treatment
of mental health conditions.
[MUSIC OUTRO]